I forget my dad's
dead leave it in leave it in three two
one German man man from Germany he swaps
what the he swaps original artwork with
fake artwork so that he could sell the
original and fund his retirment luxury
lifestyle oh this was a he for deut Mark
you guys ever watch Mr
that's pretty good how come there's
always like a genius like art thief in
Europe but in America no one is Art
Thief is he a genius or did he just
watch the Mr Bean movie oh is that what
he did I didn't watch the Mr Bean movie
oh when he messes up the mon movie he
[__] up whistler's mother which is a
famous art piece I guess and like he
just replaces it with a fakey and then
he like has the original in his house he
erased the nose right or something and
that's what this [__] guy did right
he takes a paint painting swaps it with
the fake he sells the original he buys
luxury goods including a Rolls-Royce oh
[__] expensive wrist watches and then
and he's only 30 years old right he
remains unnamed due to Germany's strict
privacy laws he was also convicted of
stealing three other artworks he avoided
jail but was handed a 21mon suspended
sentence in order to pay the museum back
more than
$644,000 wait time out time out time out
you're saying that he [__] swapped
the art piece that was able to let him
buy a rollsroyce and wristwatches but he
didn't have to go to jail and all he had
to do is pay 60,000 yes 64,000 it's cuz
Germany's woke bro so he on top then
that's hella on top on top or 500,000
the wrist washes alone might be the the
F fine he pays he didn't even have to
like restore everything to the way it
was before he did all this sh crushing
and no jail time yep what the [__]
Germany we should start committing more
crimes I think out there even in America
well you could do it here you go steal
20 Nike shoes no but that's under under
950 a grand under $950 have you guys
been a Target recently no everything is
locked up oh even CVS dude [__]
shampoo is locked up dude everything's
locked and you got to press a button to
get someone to come and bring open up
maybe I should start stealing cuz I keep
shopping on
Amazon you're so bent on of shap how
come all these people get free [__] and
I have to pay for it because you
participate you you know ret have
started participating in it's pretty
good what Amazon returns how do you how
do you parti dude some guy over here
does this [__] did you go to the place
you go to Whole Foods okay yeah and
Whole Foods has a return box and with
little baggies okay take your product
right and then you put in the bagg and
you put in the box it's automated and
there's even a person who can help you
as well but they they don't necessarily
work for Amazon so they're just like
what's your return and then if you have
the original packaging what the scanner
whatever but I'm just saying like
they'll basically take
whatever as long as it was a product on
your order list so you're talking about
fraud you're talking about no no no no
I'm talking about fraud let's say like
you bought something this is fair cuz $1
you buy something fraud and I like it
you you try it mhm and then it doesn't
work out for you in a certain period of
time you can return I see what you're
saying you know what I'm saying what is
he saying I did that with condoms and
they didn't me return it why not it's
not the same thing that's in the Box I'm
not I didn't say that I didn't say that
what are you saying I don't know I
thought you I thought you were talking
about a tuxedo that you wear for a
special occasion and then you go a
tuxedo warm you're getting warm I'm
telling you right now you're getting
warm and then you put like a [__]
Batman cape in there from Party
City he's saying he's saying you try it
and then you say I don't want it anymore
no no no no no no no what you're saying
is you go I ordered a tuxedo and I got
this shitty little Batman cape from The
Party
Store I think you guys need to get your
business uh in order tell Bezos I said
uh figure it out he's dropping the
ball Oh I thought you me you just got
the product put it on for a party and
returned it oh I see that's like I said
that's why you're warm that that's more
like it yeah yeah you save the packaging
you go I tried it
I didn't like it I didn't like it so
good like so good okay oh and here's
your
refund okay right right see you got some
Adidas Superstars yeah cuz it's a staple
shoe and you go it's kind of old man so
then you get another new pair and then
you say oh I don't like these you just
put your old pair back in and you give
them that so you always get new Shar so
smart that's what Andy did I did not do
that I didn't say anything I didn't do
anything anything okay you zy [__] you
just have a little idea I'm just
hypothetically thinking about the
Germans cuz Adidas is from Germany yeah
then that's how it's related to this you
know what you can do what's your German
accent is you could go to China and you
can buy a fake Rolex so you go to Amazon
buy a real Rolex you put you buy a real
Rolex on Amazon the box and you return
it they got or you buy you buy Apple
airpods from Amazon then you buy the
Teemu ones yeah the Chingling teu yeah
and then you put it in there and then
you return that's a good dude teu is so
annoying they email me every day trying
to be like you want to stuff in your
cart you know how it does that if you
leave it in your cart they bug you till
you freaking check out well they want me
to be an ambassador dude hell yeah check
it out so this guy he avoided jail like
I said um how however he stole a a
painting which I don't know if you guys
have ever heard of this painting I know
I never have but it's called the tale of
the Frog print
I heard of the story is this [__] this
[__] I never seen that wait you got to
show the Frog you got to scroll and show
the Frog multi-million dollar painting
right there you can barely see the Frog
the Frog's right I think the Frog's
pretty important to It's called The Tail
Of The Frog Prince why how much was that
I think it's a Banky I don't know that's
a multi-million dollar painting it's a
Banky no it's like it's worth like 50
Grand dude well how did he get a
Rolls-Royce for okay well let me down
paid it
no so he he sells that painting right
he's like a daycare worker trying to
talk to kids
no so he sells that painting right adult
daycare and he gets like he gets like 52
G's for it yeah okay so now this is
going to start to add up for you guys
right okay okay okay so remember he got
$64,000 $64,800 oh yeah so he sells that
painting for 52,000 Cas for you to Logic
the Rolls-Royce and then hold on then he
stole three other paintings right one's
called the wine test one's called two
girls collecting wood in the mountains I
think we know what that means they're
getting [__] two girls one cup or
they're just [__] each other cuz
they're they're repressed lesbians no
they're actually just holding wood oh
okay in the mountains part and then
there's another one rubbing each other's
[__] beavers
yep bunching
rugs do you think they knew how to do
that back in the day I think they
invented it back in the did they know
how to do that back in the day it
doesn't say say in the article
o o Steve Steve Steve Nick go ahead no
that was my question okay they knew how
to eat each other no lesbianism wasn't
real back then Joe it was it was
invented by Nature later still a concept
I give you iism I could give you feudal
Japanese proof that okay wood block you
have until minute 14 go forth wood block
painting no type this up what oh I'll
tell you tentacle porn's been in Japan
for a couple hundred years private
window hold on wood block Hy the [__]
guy that does the the waves yeah wood
block lesbians is that no wood block
tentacle
erotic erotic and then you'll see oh
look it's a purple link I've been
looking at it
already it's a octopus hold on it wants
me to look it wants me to select all
squares of motorcycles so that's really
complicated cuz you don't choose the guy
it's not fa don't choose don't select
his head but it's from like 16 oh but
you had to it again I know I got to do
it again I got to select all these
motorcycles this do I select the mirror
or no no is it part of the motorcycle
yes the
motorcycle hurry up I want to see some
[__] hold
on you got to wait it helps to wait what
you saying about Hokusai she not BL you
know the famous artist yeah Hokusai but
he he made pornos okay it's one of these
cuz you know how artists are always
broken [__] so like he would get hired
by brothel to make porn
porn there we go they're like come
through bro what's your point they knew
how to eat [__] [__] back in oh I
see now starting in the 16th [__] am I
right you see what I did there little
James Bond movie that's the 1400 you
said yeah it's like old old 14 or 1600
they're like and then they you know in
Vegas the Mexican dudes be giving you
porn yeah with and then they'll be like
hey do you want the flyer for the do you
want a birthday party yeah do you want a
flyer for like a private party and then
you look at it and you're like damn
she's [__] fine that's what that was
back in the day you go down the street
they'll be like hey you want a tentacle
part and [__] like that there's a
Mexican guy in Japan just going
like okay real quick credit to Joe this
is one of the other paintings that was
[__] eating [__] eating [__] this
one right here that's not a hawky that
one right there no that's not that's not
new this is Ja traditional Japanese
culture that's not H that's not M
traditional Japanese
the paintings that he sold as well
that's Modern Art
[Music]
dude